This is an exam paper from the University
of Cambridge it's part of a course which
is widely regarded as being the most demanding
undergraduate mathematics course in Britain and
that is the Mathematical Tripos. The tripos
comes in three parts spread over three years
and it is an old exam steeped in tradition
and prestige. It was introduced around 1790
and still challenges some of the smartest
students today. Some mathematicians would
like to see it abolished but for now the tripos
still has a strong grip on English higher math
education so let's take a look at it. This is
the exam that for over 200 years has been seen
as a leading test of mental agility and
stamina. It's changed a lot in that time
but the current iteration still contains all
sorts of really difficult questions. It starts
with number theory; compute the continued
fraction expansion of the square root of 29.
Then an analysis proof then a cryptography
question asking one to describe the
Berlekamp-Massey method for breaking
a cipher stream arising from a
linear feedback shift register.
This is one of the four papers which a student
would take in their third year of the tripos.
After this they can leave with a bachelor's degree
or do one more year of study called part three to
obtain a masters of math. You'll notice though
that this one exam paper contains questions on
everything from number theory to coding to
statistics, quantum mechanics and analysis.
It’s more common elsewhere to see these
different areas of math separated into
different modular exams where you
only need to study for one at a time.
That’s not the case here, all the subjects are
considered together but you do get to pick and
chose which questions to tackle. This approach
allows students to attend whatever courses
and lectures they wish and then choose
how they want to prepare for the exam.
Heres the list of courses on offer in
third year. I’m drawn to see what exam
questions look like for some of these,
for example math of machine learning.
This is the 2022 question they are asked
to write down and adaboost algorithm,
to say what is meant by a convex hull
and a convex combination of vectors,
what is meant by the empirical Rademacher
complexity. Here's the syllabus for the
mathematics of machine learning course to see
the other kind of ideas that go into this math.
Cambridge now has many triposes for several
different courses including an english tripos
and natural sciences tripos but it used to be
just math. The exam originally took the form of a
debate where the student had to wrangle logic but
then became what might be the oldest university
written exam in the world. The original exam
was called the Senate House exam because that’s
the name of the building where it was taken.
The oldest copy of the exam that I could find
was this one from 1841. The questions
are also difficult, but different
Solve the following equations and show that a
quadratic equation cannot have more than two
roots. Prove that in a spherical triangle any
one side is greater than the difference between
the two others. Enunciate and prove the tenth
Lemma of Newton's first section. They expected
students to be familiar with Newton's work in
a way that no student is today if I pull out
my handy Principia we might be able to get the
answer to this one. Okay this looks like Lemma
10 in the first section; The spaces which a
body describes by a finite force urging it
whether that force is determined and immutable or
is continually augmented or continually diminished
are in the very beginning of the motion to each
other as the squares of the times. hmm. The focus
on Newton does make sense since Newton did study
in Cambridge and heavily influenced the British
math scene. Give the arguments for supposing
the earth to be round and on the supposition
of its being a sphere investigate a formula for
calculating approximately the dip of the horizon.
This older exam was a true mental agility and
endurance test there are 12 papers to be taken
two a day for six days it's a week-long marathon
answering hundreds of questions for five and a
half hours a day students trained for it like
an Olympic sport. The highest scoring student
was called the Senior Wrangler and became a minor
celebrity. I found the scores for an exam in the
1860s which gives an idea of scoring around
this time and out of a possible mark of 17000
the senior Wrangler scored only about 7600,
second place scored about 4100 and the lowest
scoring candidate to still pass scored just 237
points and earned the special Wooden Spoon award.
The 1841 results are listed here with Stokes
the Senior Wrangler. That is George Stokes
now famous for the Navier-Stokes equation in
fluid mechanics and Stokes' theorem in vector
calculus. You might have been examined on those
ideas yourself and now you've seen the exact exam
questions Stokes faced as a student. Let's compare
some similar questions from then and now. Given
that this exam took place before Einstein's work
on relativity we can't expect much of an analog
to this general relativity question but there are
plenty of questions about Newtonian gravity. 1841
was before we developed astronomical spectroscopy
or measured the expansion of the universe so this
cosmology question would blow the mind of even
an 1841 Senior Wrangler- but wait actually George
Stokes apparently is credited with inventing
the fundamental principles of spectroscopy.
Modern quantum mechanics wasn't to be invented
for another 60 years so we won't see that but
there are plenty of questions about light
and we won't find much machine learning,
statistical modeling or coding and cryptography
in the 1841 paper since there were no computers.
These are the best I could find to resemble the
modern number theory and analysis questions.
Training for the tripos has historically
involved external coaching to help students
increase the speed that they can solve and
write out solutions and the whole process
has been criticized for not allowing enough
time for a deep understanding or to make
investigations which are important skills
for mathematician and the Senior Wrangler
has not always turned out to be the most
distinguished mathematician later in life.
One notable critic of the tripos was G H Hardy,
Ramanujan's mentor, Hardy gave an address to the
mathematical Association in 1926 calling to
abolish the tripos completely he said that
the ability to show originality in mathematics
can't be tested under exam conditions and so the
exam reduces to a kind of game. A student can
choose to play the game with all their force
but must realize they are putting their
mathematical development on hold to do
so. The prestige and status of the tripos forces
many students to devote everything to the game.
Hardy isn't against exams in general and knows
they are useful to test students but he wants
exams that do not profess to be more than a
reasonable test of certain humdrum qualities.
The qualities worth testing on an exam would
carry any student at Cambridge to second class
and beyond that he does not believe in recognizing
differences of ability by examination. The tripos
is an exam that attempted to sort students right
to the top, today students are no longer publicly
ranked in order but the Senior Wrangler
is still acknowledged during the reading
of results at Senate House. Students today might
still relate to the idea of having to put their
real mathematical pursuits on hold in order
to play the game. Hardy says if Einstein had
taken the tripos what would it matter what place
he took? Students are driven to perform in the
exams by tutors and greedy college authorities. "I
do not want to reform the tripos but destroy it,
but neither I nor anyone else will succeed in
doing so since the practical difficulties would
be so serious and the force of tradition is
so terribly strong." Some things have changed
since 1926. Hardy's view is that the tripos should
produce research mathematicians but not everyone
studying math has that aim. The modern day tripos
website is proud that the course prepares students
for a range of jobs not just academia. Let
me show you one more interesting past paper,
this was the first page of the tripos exam in 1890
and was the exam taken by Philippa Fawcett. She
wasn't the first woman to sit the math tripos but
was the first to rank number one. As the results
of the exam were announced the men's results were
read first and then the women's. Women weren't
officially ranked but were placed relative to the
men. Fawcett was placed above the Senior Wrangler
and Senate House erupted in celebration. She beat
the Senior Wrangler by 400 marks and her success
was headline news. It took another 58 years
before women were actually allowed to receive
degrees from Cambridge. Today the results are read
out in alphabetical order rather than by rank,
but what do you think does the tripos deserve to
be destroyed as Hardy wanted or is it a worthy
challenge that motivates students to perform at
their best? Thanks for watching and a special
thank you to my Patreon supporters including
today's Patron cats of the day Pan and Tilt.